notably talking about the fact that
James Marrs that in Kate Bosworth our
couple again they were a couple in
Superman Returns I didn't even notice as
I was watching the movie I was like
something's weird oh yeah it's beautiful
must be great growing up here we don't
trust each other here we don't even lock
our doors I saw you in a picture wearing
the cheerleading uniform do you think
that storage for you I'd like that
drawing dogs is a remake of a 1971 film
I believe with Dustin Hoffman and 40
years that's fair time for a remake I
mean now that we're making everything
from the 80s and you're like come on 40
years I can understand in remaking this
this film stars James Marsden and Kate
Bosworth and they're a couple who are
going back to Bosworth hometown from
when she was a child and it's like this
very rural area of Mississippi and there
he's going there so he can get some
peace so he can write the screenplay is
working on they encounter some locals
who aren't pleased with them being there
and they cause a lot of strain and
tension and problems and it leads to a
serious conflict between these two
groups of people which forces James
Marsden to defend his own house mrs.
owner Charlie put in a bid for me and my
crew to rebuild a trophy oh yeah that's
right can you start tomorrow
the original film was considered very
inappropriate when I first came out it
was actually banned in the United
Kingdom and a lot of people were not
happy with the film and some of the
things that depicted I've seen about the
first 30 minutes or so of the original I
started watching it last night and from
what I can see they're doing pretty much
the exact same things it's just that
they're setting it in a different
location changing a few random things so
with this fella really seems like
they're trying to remake the film but
there's a tone in it that's a little bit
off it's a little more fun and silly
than the original which was a lot more
serious and a little bit more dreadful
so this film sometimes comes off that
way it comes off a little cheesy
sometimes but they're still trying to
depict the same intense thing to the
original film did but they're not really
going all the way for it in the tone my
audience was laughing a lot and I don't
think that the filmmakers were intending
for that to happen
little early anything that's the way we
do things around here you get used to it
okay thank you guys all right
the real problem of this movie is the
tone I think that it's trying to depict
really intense serious events that would
traumatize your average person but the
tone of the film is kind of fun like and
so it doesn't really it doesn't really
mesh well and so when these really bad
things are happening sometimes the
audience was actually laughing a little
bit and I think it's because the
audience couldn't really tell or decide
what tone the filmmakers are going for
were they pear eating themselves were
they being really silly on purpose or
were they trying to be intense and just
not really working out as well as it
should
are you right man that ain't right I
don't know what a ride is thanks for
practically licking my body outside I
can't just walk out there and accuse
them you're a coward
I thought Marsden was good in this film
I liked James Marsden I think he's a
good actor I've liked him in everything
I've seen him in I think that he has a
lot of charisma and haman Kate Bosworth
worked really well together and they had
good chemistry I thought Bosworth is
good as well it's just that character
motivations in this movie make no sense
all the way from Kate Bosworth basically
begging the guys to attack her character
motivations in this film I don't
understand I can't even explain my two
biggest problems with this movie because
there's boilers so I'll just say that
characters have certain things done to
them and then never spoken of again
never discussed again never hinted at
again so much potential is in two scenes
in this movie for some serious dramatic
effect for something that just happened
but the filmmakers just disregard
completely and I really don't understand
why they would do such a thing I'm
firing tomorrow not only that how much
they gonna pay us don't worry about it
we're all gonna get we deserve
Straw Dogs is in no way a horrible movie
there are definitely good things about
it there there are things about the film
I liked it was never boring it was never
unwatchable I never minded the fact that
I was watching the movie and I liked
most of the actors in the film too it's
just that there are certain things that
film sets up but it never goes for it
never goes for some of the from some of
the dramatic effect and punch of some of
the things that they're setting up
they're trying to be serious and really
gritty and intense and everything but
they're kind of it's kind of fun and
silly and I don't understand really the
vibe they're going for one thing they're
not gonna come out guys we have to get
you take it in this house we're dead now
the film's finale I thought was riveting
I really liked the finale of the movie
even though some of the things that
happened I was like it doesn't make
sense also without spoiling anything at
all I would say this film has one of the
best on-screen deaths I have ever seen
in my life
the audience went wild I mean it was it
was very well done I really liked it the
tone of this movie is just off the tone
of this movie is like the freakin Rocky
Mountains I don't know what's going on
it's just up and down up and down up and
down goes from silly to fun to to
light-hearted to crazy intense to weird
and then back to fun I don't know to
tell the movies off I think that's
really the problem of the movie so I'm
gonna give Straw Dogs a C+ that's my
house I will not allow violence against
this house
so of course I'm not gonna really
recommend seeing strong locks in
theatres maybe if you rented it got it
off a Netflix or something and watched
it at home and be a lot more fun I think
if you liked my review you can subscribe
to my channel and get stopping eyes